and Mer sent me this
I thought we'd have some fun yeah let's
have fun why don't we
are
your songs on YouTube and you're
monetized yeah and you have no you're
not you've I don't think you've actually
can I ask a a valid point has
anyone
ever censored Tom McDonald no no one has
ever censored him ever there's not an
instance of him being centered my
favorite quote of Tom McDonald was the
same him same people shouldn't praise
Kyle Rittenhouse because he killed
somebody on a rolling stone article that
he did
[Music]
we the go okay I'm sorry Thomas can I
can I call you Thomas
the the thing that you're the thing that
you're that you're that you're talking
about the badass military that you're
talking about
we just had a video of the badass
military person that you're talking
about where where did I put it
no that's there she is no that's
God damn it I lost a [__] it was it was
the truth whatever the Tran yeah yeah
all right also Tom fight and take the
country back we're not even allowed to
have a rally because if a couple people
break windows and somebody steals a
Podium everyone goes to prison for life
yeah
but make sure the Cal Rittenhouse no one
Praises him right now don't want to do
that Tom right
um okay hold on uh this is perfect this
is this is what this is ready
this is
the military
that you order
and the military that you get from wish
how's that oh that [__] mug man
[__]
and every time
oh yeah we love Ukraine give money to
Ukraine we [__] Love Ukraine right
Tom
you're not an American citizen you can't
own a gun you're Canadian I'm so sick of
all Americans being Canadian now is this
is this like the the his new
controversial uh top position is
American flags are good yeah we've gone
we've gone full circle we're back at
2001 post 911.
[Music]
yeah you guys are American flags but the
L is silent
[Laughter]
okay
[Music]
yeah when was the last time that style
of rapping was relevant I don't know man
when did Eminem come out yeah Bob then
when was the last twister song
I'm the white boy with the middle
fingers
like all right to make to make a point
right to compare it to Modern rap right
I have listened to some Drake songs
where he says and does very little right
but like the way the beat is and the way
he does it it who put out a banger where
he barely says or does anything on it
and it's like very minimalist and Tom's
going back to 2004 where it's like
Fitness many words
are you doing that all [__] silly
at least they were good though at least
they were good
wait was that a real line in this rap
song
did you hear that part your child Thomas
[Music]
did they just rap we think that is this
a Lonely Island Song yes what is this no
because the Lonely Island Song would be
like intentionally foreign
[Music]
Thomas
he's so cringe he's so [__] cringe
the only thing you're gonna smash is
Blair white again you know we were
here's the thing and there was like a
small window
with tiny small window right after Trump
got elected when when like the right was
like cool it was a small win it was like
three months right remember and well and
leading up to Trump right right right
right so so let's give us there was
there was like six months
in total that the right was being kind
of cool counterculture I would give it a
year okay I would I would give them a
solid year before we before it really
went uh oh and then it's this and then
people praise this just because he's
saying the stuff you want to hear
he's a meme
go look seriously look up Tom McDonald
Kyle Rittenhouse Rolling Stone see what
he said about him
because that's what this guy is a phone
he's on YouTube and he's [__]
monetized he's not saying anything edgy
nobody's saying anything edgy or
controversial is left on YouTube anymore
yeah he's he's uh
he's basically uh uh we're letting
illegals flood into our country and get
welfare but we can't take care of our
homeless vets the person yeah thank you
it's like I know we know I heard it a
million times yeah we know I don't know
[__] man all right all right we have to
we have we'll keep playing more but we
have to look
for the comments and we always look for
the comments I don't like rap usually
but but this guy's good okay let's see
what we got here
Tom I'm an 11 year old girl and me and
my dad love your music so the dad typed
that uh I'm English okay this is crazy
isn't it
that is creepy if the Dad's doing that
as a non-tattooed 58 year old male thank
you Tom for your leadership and
patriotism your message is working
that's close that's close
oh my God this hit hard what
literally made me tear up because how
much I love my country and how much I
know they want to destroy it bro Trump
broke these brains on both sides like
like I don't think people remember Trump
derangement Syndrome works both ways
right
yeah did you guys forget that like you
know we all kind of laughed when people
got so [__] broken by Trump that they
had to destroy Trump and we could
trigger him with just a simple Trump
meme right
but now some of you some of you [__]
got so sucked into the other side of
trump that you're deranged because
you're obsessed with them and you think
he's like the god you think you think
all the god Emperor [__] is real yeah we
were kidding when we were posting that
[__] on Paul it was because when you
posted fashion images of trump right
after he won these [__] like
journalists were melting down at
BuzzFeed and they're like they were
seeing Nazis everywhere and it was funny
now it's like
um here's one this song definitely
bleeds libtard tears I love it
does it oh my God that's the [__]
America can I ask are there any liberals
that listen to Tom McDonald and go ah
or like like we hate watching them yeah
because it's fun but is the left hate
watching them no they're always like wow
spilling more liberal tears when has I
I've never seen anyone on the left
have a Tom McDonald related meltdown
he's not even good at throwing because
the left is listening to the weekend
they're you know what I'm saying like
they're not this is stupid this is not
how you [__] win the culture war that
you guys are trying to do this is
[__] cringe you these people want to
like destroy the left by being them yeah
you take what they make
you take what they make and then they go
they're horrible but now there's cool
tricks
okay that's fine but all you're doing is
playing catch up to what they're doing
you're playing catch-up and you're not
going to catch up here's the problem
it's not enough collaborations
artists from different genres need to
support each other that's how we destroy
Hollywood hear me out on this Tom
McDonald does a guest appearance in the
next issue of Isom
boom
and then and then Eric July does a a a
collab
like a rap rock a rap rock song yeah
yeah yeah yeah see I'm already thinking
nice
I swear to [__] Christ almighty if
this happens I'm going to fly down to
[__] Florida and bomb your house oh
you didn't know I'm Dan Aykroyd he's
Ghostbusters yeah no I'm Dan Aykroyd
from Ghostbusters I do this [__] on
purpose I'm constantly thinking of a new
destroyer but he drinks like Dan ackward
from real life yes uh king of all yetis
and Dan Aykroyd from the show where he
was a priest oddly enough which was
weird I don't know why he was drinking
so much Rory says gonna act like he
don't bump the weekend I love the
weekend I'm not saying I don't like that
we love the weekend that's not what I'm
saying but what I'm saying is it's like
they have enough good music this they
don't care about this this doesn't get
in their heads because they don't give a
[__] this is cringe when people like us
who look
it's something that you disagree with
what he's saying but it's not real it's
manufactured [__] to trying to
pretend like you're the edgy cool oh
good face stats shut the [__] up man you
look like a short order cook at the
Cheesecake Factory I'm really [__]
sick of the right just consuming
something not because of the quality of
it not because it's [__] good or
funny or entertaining or interesting
it's because we have to support this guy
he's saying we want to hear that's why
you buy 27 chocolate bars from the daily
wire
you idiots
I don't get it I don't understand people
that this is bad this is cringe this is
not good
music rap it's cringy because what I do
is look I put myself in I here's the
stuff you defend stuff you know
different right you put yourself in the
shoes of a consumer of rap is what right
now like a 16 year old kid right some 16
year old kids consuming rap and I think
back when I wasn't political when I was
just a kid growing up if I saw this I go
this is corny as [__] not knowing the
message not knowing anything you would
go what is it this is so gay and when
your target audience is 58 year old
people that already agree with you
you're not fighting a culture War what
you're doing is you're Bob Hope and
you're entertaining the troops yeah
you're pandering for cash yeah exactly
you're selling war bonds you're doing a
soft shoe
you know you're not changing any Minds
you think some [__] liberal that was
at an antifa rally went you know what I
was gonna go into another rally but then
I heard this Tom McDonald Banger because
that comes up in his algorithm and I was
like you know what it changed my point
of view I'm all about America the right
the the registered sex offender member
of antifa in Portland was like you know
what
you're right maybe I haven't been pretty
hard on America yeah no
no you're not in the same way as mercy
and I are gonna come across episode of
queer kid stuff and be like you know
what
what is has a point she really changed
her mind there isn't enough queer
content for babies no guys
be funny be entertaining I'm not saying
don't do those things but don't try to
copy them and be like look at us we're
just like you we're cool no these guys
are terrible you know you know who's
been mentioned by us uh once before and
in a non-negative light Hassan [__] and
Hassan pikers mentioned us before see
you can actually end up in other
people's fears sometimes you're just
occasionally funny yeah that's all you
gotta know just be funny all you have to
do is be funny and I hate a song I don't
see him hide squeeze every ounce of
[__] oxygen out of his body but you
know the I [__] Dan Crenshaw thing was
hilarious uh because that's something I
agree with remember what was the what
was the other thing when somebody was
like your revenge of the CIS or
something and he's like I don't think
those guys are gonna like me I don't
think those guys are gonna like me was
his comment when someone brought a lift
I don't think these guys are gonna like
me
but like see you're gonna be that's a
guy that we hate and is on the other
side of everything polar opposite but
can make me [__] like Bill Maher
makes us laugh Bill Mark can be very
funny I I think he's I think that he's
now living in the [__] he's living in
the world that he helped create because
we told him was going to go too far and
he didn't listen but that being said
sometimes he has lines that are funny
cumia still makes me laugh yeah